[Musique]
bienvenue au tribunal de Versailles
tribunal qui est une longue et grande
histoire c'est ici qu'il y a un peu plus
de 100 ans a été jugé un des grands
criminels de notre histoire criminelle
qui était Henri désiré landondru on en
parlera tout à l'heure puisqu'il y a une
pièce qui va se jouer sur ce procès avec
londru lui-même qui va revenir sur les
sur les traces de de l'endroit où il a
été jugé on parlera aussi de de fait
d'ivers et de grands procès qui ont eu
lieu à versaill avec hélè charabani hélè
charabani est conférencière à l'Office
de Tourisme de Versailles et puis le
tribunal de Versailles c'est un tribunal
très actuel et et Bertrand Menet bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le président de de ce
tribunal on est donc chez vous en
quelque sorte oui bienvenue cas quelque
sorte alors c'est un tribunal important
je crois que c'est 75
magistrats une trentaine de de
magistrats du parquet plus de de de 300
fonctionnaires tout à fait oui voilà
donc versaill dans le tribunal dans sa
configuration actuelle c'est
effectivement le 8e tribunal en terme
d'importance en France c'està-dire qu'on
on englobe dans cette importance la la
notion de nombre d'affaires traitées
tant au civil qu'on pénal on en parlera
et effectivement c'est ça c'est une
centaine de magistrats divisés entre le
siège 75 le parquet 31 et puis 320
fonctionnaires qui nous sont
indispensables pour travailler justement
puisque vous dites magistrat du siège
magistrat du parquet tout le monde
connaît pas la la la différence on dit
aussi magistrature assise magistrature
debout hein tout à fait euh puisque il y
a certains magistrats sont assis ce sont
ceux qui jugent et puis ceux qui
requierèrent sont sont debout euh en un
mot la différence entre ces deux types
de magistrats alors peut-être ce qu'il
faut savoir très vite c'est que d'abord
les magistrats en France contrairement à
d'autres pays ne sont pas élus ils ont
euh nommés sur décision du Président de
la République après avoir réussi un
concours et les magistrats du siège et
les magistrats du parquet donc tous
ensemble suivent la même formation et on
peut être tantôt l'un ou l'autre alors
en gros qu'est-ce que ça veut dire dans
notre quotidien le magistrat du parquet
est le procureur ou c'est substitut il
est chargé de surveiller l'action de la
police de recueillir les plaintes et
puis ensuite d'orienter les affaires
vers un tribunal un tribunal
correctionnel le plus souvent ou un
tribunal de police pour faire juger
l'affaire il soutient l'accusation en
quelque sorte et puis un juge donc des
magistrats du siège trois juges en
général ou un parfois eux sont chargés
d'apprécier tous les éléments d'entendre
tout le monde le procureur mais aussi la
défense et puis enfin de trancher
l'affaire donc voilà il y a celui qui
propose une sanction et puis il y a le
juge le juge qui juge l'affaire voilà
vous vous-même enfin vous êtes un juge
du siège évidemment vous auriez pu être
tenté par par être magistrat du parquet
ah je je l'ai été je n'ai pas été
magistrat du parquet mais j'ai été tenté
après voilà c'est au cours d'une
carrière on change de fonction quand
même assez régulièrement et puis parfois
les choses se font et d'autres fois ne
se font pas pour moi ça ne s'est pas
présenté effectivement même si certaines
de mes demandes un temps portaient
également sur des sur des poes du par
j'aurais pu le l'être mais le hasard a
voulu que que que je fasse autre chose
et j'ai été nommé sur d'autres postes
toujours effectivement toujours au siège
oui B d'abord vous êtes breton oui voilà
je suis je suis René tout à fait euh
c'est dire que le tribunal de Versailles
se dit par des gens qui ont une forte
person ité euh vous avez vous avez
d'ailleurs commencé à Saint-Brieux je
crois le premier stage hein c'est ça
c'està dire que pendant qu'on est à
l'école de la magistrature qui est à
bord on fait on fait 3 ans de scolarité
après nos études de droit donc c'est
quand même un parcours assez assez long
et on passe une année complète à
Bordeaux où on a une formation très
théorique et puis ensuite on passe une
année et demi environ dans un tribunal
un peu partout en France et j'ai fait et
donc on fait un stage cette fois très
pratique où on va à côté de magistrat
professionnel en exercice et on se met
dans la situation du stagiaire en
quelque sorte qui qui va tenir des
audiences et j'ai fait ce stage là
pendant un peu plus d'un an et demi à
saint-briux et je crois non je dis ça
parce que je crois que Madame CBOT qui
est la procureur de la République est
originaire de saint-vriilleux tout à
fait ça vous fait des liens dans dans
des dans des moments différents on s'est
jamais rencontré en Bretagne mais
effectivement à des moments différents
on a eu des parcours tous les deux à
saint-riux absolument alors après vous
avez été anoncii vous avez été président
du du tribunal despinal et vous avez
aussi exercé une fonction nationale
l'inspection générale du du ministère
des de la justice euh vous diriez au
fond jusqu'à arriver à la présidence de
ce tribunal ça c'est un parcours qui a
une unité ou plutôt avec des des
fonctions diverses qui vous permettent
aujourd'hui de de de mieux diriger
peut-être un un un tribunal comme celui
de Versailles il y a eu deux temps il y
a eu un temps où j'ai eu effectivement
des fonctions très diversifiées vous
l'avez dit j'ai commencé comme juge
d'instance dans un petit tribunal dans
dans une petite ville enfin une ville
moyenne disons c'était toule à côté de
Nancy et puis ensuite j'ai exercé des
fonctions de ce qu'on appelle juge placé
juge placé c'est un peu le le remplaçant
pendant 5 ans on est appelé sur sur
différentes fonctions juge des enfants
juge d'instruction enfin on fait plein
de choses dans plein d'endroits
différents donc ce qui m'a donné une
grande diversité d'exercices de fonction
et ce qui m'a donné la possibilité de de
voilà de Me confrontter à beaucoup de
réalités différentes les affaires
familiales les enfants je le disais
enfin voilà toutes les fonctions du
siège et puis après et bien au au gré
d'une nomination déjà comme président
c'était pour la première fois à barleduc
a 20 ans et et donc j'ai suivi en plus
d'une filière de de de dire le droit de
continuer à dire le droit de continuer à
juger parce que dans des petites
juridictions on juge beaucoup continue à
juger même quand on est encore président
même le président juge beaucoup mais
effectivement j'ai aussi endossé des
fonctions administratives de de
responsabilité et de gestion d'un
tribunal puisque le président dans la
juridiction en en discussion avec le
avec le procureur et avec une directrice
pour les effectifs de Greff et bien tous
les trois on on conduit un peu au
destiné de la juridiction on définit les
orientations voilà donc donc début d'un
parcours diversifié et puis ensuite
orientation plus vers des fonctions
d'administration de gestion tout en
gardant toujours une part de une part de
de de de juridiction et de
juridictionnel puisque voilà c'est ce
qui fait aussi la spécificité des des
tribunaux français c'est qu'ils sont
gouvernés en quelque sorte par par des
magistrats le le métier finalement de de
président de de tribunal tel que vous
l'exercez aujourd'hui bah c'est diriger
d'abord cette cette juridiction diriger
les magistrats qui sont qui sont là de
faire en sorte que tout se passe le
mieux possible c'est ça oui tout à fait
c'est organiser le le service de chacun
des 75 magistrats du siège pour ceux qui
me concerne et puis Madame le Procureur
s'occupe de ces 30 substituts donc c'est
pouvoir définir combien de juges on
affecte aux affaires familiales nous en
avons 10 ici au tribunal combien de
juges des enfants combien de juges de
l'application des peines combien de
juges d'instruction combien de juges
pour le service pénal le correctionnel
combien de juges pour les affaires
civiles enfin voilà donc vous vous
imaginez et puis ensuite être le guide
un petit peu pouvoir discuter avec les
collègues faire leur évaluation vérifier
comment les choses comment les choses
s'organisent d'une manière générale
gérer le budget gérer l'immobilier la
sécurité voilà un certain nombre de
choses qui qui concernent la vie de
d'une grosse structure administrative
parle de juge des fabille de juge
d'instruction à l'instant c'est vrai
qu'il y a deux grandes fonctions dans un
tribunal il y a de justice si je peux
dire la justice civile c'estàd les
conflits entre les particuliers les
divorces je sais pas qu' Favec entre
locataire propriétaire et puis et puis
la justice pénal c'està-dire les délits
hein dans tribunal euh dans dans je
parlais des divorces euh dans dans le la
justice civile les plus grosses affaires
qui qui sont traité dans un tribunal
comme versaill c'est quoi ah bah la part
effectivement la part de la des affaires
familiales d'une manière générale donc
les divorce mais aussi le contentieux
des affaires familiales c'est aussi
toutes les toutes les familles qui ne
sont pas mariées hein les les hommes les
femmes ou les couples qui qui qui se
désunissent le plus souvent donc pour
pour régler lorsqu'ils ne s'entendent
pas pour régler le leur différents en
particulier évidemment les différents
liés aux enfants ou euh et euh aussi les
les différents liés à aux biens qu'ils
ont en commun donc le juge aux affaires
familiales va être amené à à trancher
tous ces problèmes le le le tribunal
reste aussi évidemment et vous le disiez
très justement c'est aussi le l'endroit
où on va faire régler son conflit régler
son différent enfin on l'espère en tout
cas c'est-à-dire qu'évidemment on ne
connaît pas de l'activité on connaît un
peu que que que des problèmes des gens
lorsque lorsque les personnes viennent
voir c'est qu'ils ont un problème euh et
donc évidemment il y a aussi toutes les
affaires familiales qui se passent bien
et les séparations qui se passent bien
d'ailleurs on parlera tout à l'heure
peut-être de la médiation qui une chose
sur laquelle vous assistez peut-être
évite justement les les procès euh donc
il y a cette justice civile il y a il y
a aussi la justice pénale et je je crois
que dans l'audience de de rentrée cette
année il a été évoqué le fait que bah le
nombre de
plaintes
augmenteugment d'une année sur l'autre
euh ça dit est-ce que ça dit quelque
chose de notre société on on parle
souvent de judiciarisation des des des
relations est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous constatez au fond oui je crois
qu'on peut faire ce constat d'une
manière général on peut faire ce constat
qu'effectivement les gens se tournent
plus facilement vers vers la justice
vers les services de police pour se
plaindre bon alors évidemment ça ne veut
pas dire qu' qu'il se plaignent pour
rien il y a aussi une augmentation d'une
certaine manière d'un certain nombre de
faits et les plus notables on en parle
beaucoup vous le savez ces dernières
années c'est tout ce qui est lié à la
relation on parlait de la relation
familiale et c'est tout tout le conflit
tout les violence intrafamilial qui ont
qui ont une réalité un petit peu un
petit peu multiforme c'est la violence
dans le couple mais c'est aussi la
violence vis-à-vis des enfants voilà
c'est toutes ces questions qui
aujourd'hui avec quand même une parole
qui s'est libéré et à juste une
attention plus grande des services de
police de G alors c'est ça qui est
compliqué en criminologie on parle
parfois de chiffre noir enfin choses
comme ça mais c'està dire que il y a en
effet plus de plaines dans ces violences
intrafamiliales euh ça on peut dire
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle parce que ça
prouve qu'il y a plus de violence c'est
peut-être aussi d'une certaine façon
entre guillemets une bonne nouvelle
parce que bah il y a plus d'attention et
c'est plus réprimé et et la parole comme
vous dis comme vous disiez se libère oui
effectivement moi je je dirais
effectivement que c'est pas ce n'est pas
pour nous ce n'est pas une mauvaise
nouvelle même si évidemment c'est un
surcroix d'activité important puisque on
est quand même sur des augmentations
constatées à peu près de 20 % ce qui qui
est déjà beaucoup mais il y a des trait
près différencier d'abord les services
de de police de gendarmerie ensuite
l'activité de Madame le Procureur bon je
je communiquerai pas à sa place mais et
puis ce qui arrive devant le tribunal
sont les affaires les plus graves tout
le reste a été traité avant c'est-à-dire
que ça n'est pas non plus parce qu'il y
a une plainte qu'il y aura
nécessairement une poursuite tout ça est
apprécié par Madame le Procureur et ses
équipes et puis ensuite on propose au
tribunal de sanctionner les faits les
plus grave ouais et il puis il y a la
mise en place de de de certaines euh une
initiative qui qui permet aussi par
exemple le téléphone de grande
urgenceél
dangerec ça c'est formidable parce que
ça souvent enfin
je pour aller vite les les les les maris
ou les compagnons jaloux espionnent les
les téléphone de de leurs femmes voilà
et là ça permet de de de bah de d'être
en contact avec la police notamment
c'est exactement ça sans que personne ne
puisse le savoir he c'est ça c'est
exactement ça c'est-à-dire que par ex
exemple un conjoint pour reprendre
l'exemple que vous donniez un conjoint
jaloux violent menaçant vis-à-vis de de
sa conjointe bien sûr ils sont séparé
voilà la femme se sent en insécurité et
sous l'appréciation de Madame le
Procureur on va pouvoir la doter d'un
téléphone grave danger le compagnon ne
le sait pas hein et cette femme ainsi a
un numéro d'appel c'est un ça se
présente sous forme d'un téléphone il
suffit d'appuyer sur un bouton de
manière continue et ça met la personne
en relation avec les services de police
et ça déclenche évidemment une
intervention immédiate avec une
géolocalisation qui permet un certain
nombre de femmes de de de se sentir un
peu plus sécurisé alors il y a aussi
dans les augmentations tout ce qui
concerne les mineurs oui et et il y a
notamment quelque chose d'assez nouveau
c'est la compar immédiate des des munur
qui est possible aujourd'hui alors oui
c'est c'est c'est oui oui vous avez
raison c'est disons on vient de le voir
avec faire de harcellement là qui a fait
un peoui tout à fait disons c'est
surtout ce qu'on appelle la présentation
immédiate c'est c'est une mesure qui
permet surtout maintenant de raccourcir
les délais de jugement des mineurs c'est
un peu ça on a eu l'entrée en vigueur du
de d'un nouveau code pour les mineurs
qu'on appelle le code de justice pénale
des mineurs on parlait souvent d'une
ordonnance qui datait de 1945 qui a été
donc toiletté il y a un nouveau code de
justice pour les mineurs justice pénale
et ce code qui est entré en application
à l'automne 2021 impose au juges de
statuer dans des délais beaucoup plus
courts c'est-à-dire que le juge voit le
mineur auteur d'un fait au plus au plus
tard dans les 3 mois de la Commission du
fait il doit se prononcer sur la
culpabilité du mineur et ensuite il
prend une mesure éducative dans
l'attente de prononcer une sanction et
cette sanction tient compte de
l'évolution de ce mineur pendant les 6
mois qui vont suivre et la sanction
arrive au plus t au plus tard dans les 9
mois qui suivent la commission des faits
bien sûr pour les affaires qui sont sont
jugées donc les juges des enfants
ontd exactement c'est vrai qu'avant les
tribunaux pour enfants étaient quand
même très encombrés et quelquefois les
jugements pouvaient intervenir un peu
tardivement donc voilà
effectivement c'est tout à fait vrai euh
je je parlais tout à l'heure je crois
que c'est aussi un engagement du du Gard
des sa mais vous êtes revenu dans
l'audience de de rentrée sur bah les
procédures justement de
conciliation de de et de oui de de
l'amiable enfin c'est vrai que on dit
toujours voilà un mauvais accord vaut
mieux qu'un un bon accord vaut mieux
qu'un mauvais procès hein oui oui c'est
c'est
formu c'est c'est une formule assez
juste on peut on peut le dire c'estàd
que faut voir que là on parle bien sûr
d'affaires civiles on parle
pas bien entendu et dans ces cas-là il y
a un principe fondamental c'est que
l'affaire civile c'est d'abord l'affaire
des partis voilà oui c'est des conflits
autre privés a person pr ex si je veux
si vous avez des personnes très très
déterminées qui ne veulent qui ne
voudront jamais s'arranger par exemple
avec leurs voisins qui veulent
absolument que ce soit le juge qui
tranche alors bien dans ces conditions
comment ça se passe bah très simplement
on disc
on fait des conclusions on reconclut
voilà ça peut durer très longtemps et et
nous notre rôle c'est parfois aussi de
faire comprendre aux personnes qui
viennent nous voir que sans sans
remettre en cause l'importance de de de
leur conflit ou pas mais c'est de leur
faire comprendre que peut-être que
plutôt que de faire durer l'affaire on
peut avoir un intérêt à se mettre autour
d'une table à discuter avec la présence
d'un tiers qui qui n'est pas là pour
dire comment l'un et l'autre doit se
positionner mais qui est là pour pour
restaurer aussi quelquefois un dialogue
entre les deux et c'est ce qu'on appelle
donc la médiation et on voit bien qu'en
matière civile la médiation fonctionne
plutôt pas mal et nous avons pris ici à
Versailles c'est une c'est une
initiative moi que que j'ai souhaité
mettre en place un dispositif très
innovant qui n'existe nulle part
ailleurs qui est un dispositif où mes
collègues dans les chambres civiles
sélectionneent un certain nombre de de
de dossiers quel que soit le niveau
d'avancement du dossier ça peut être au
démarrage ou ça peut même être proche de
la fin il sélectionneent un certain
nombre de dossiers qui leur apparaissent
vraiment mérités que les partis se
parlent parce qu'un dialogue est Romu
depuis longtemps ou parce que
quelquefois la décision de justice ne ne
résoudra pas le fond du problème je vous
donnerai des exemples si vous voulez et
donc j'ai demandé à mes collègues de
sélectionner un certain nombre de
dossiers on les sort de de nos armoires
on convoque spécialement les personnes
les partis avec leurs avocats et le juge
reçoit les partis avec leurs avocats et
avec un médiateur et on fait une
information pendant 1 heure on explique
aux gens ce qu'est la médiation et on
leur propose de par par en médiation
dans des délais raccourcis ça dure 3
mois dans des coûts limités c'est en
moyenne 500 € par partie al bien sûr ça
peut paraître élevé comme ça mais quand
on connait le coût quand on connait le
coût d'un procès avec les frais d'avocat
et cetera c'est quand même relativement
raisonable et puis surtout on leur
propose quasiment en 3 mois de régler
leurs problèmes et sont les juges qui
font la voilà c'est en cela alors les
juges ne font pas la médiation les juges
font l'information c'estd qu'ils
expliquent au partis quel est leur
intérêt aussi à s'engager dans ce
processus et c'est en cel où c'est
nouveau c'est d que moi j'ai souhaité
qu'il y ait un juge et un médiateur qui
reçoiv ensemble les partis qui expliqu
et puis si les partis sont d'accord pour
aller sur ce terrain mais de la
médiation on leur fixe tout de suite un
rendez-vous devant un médiateur et là
ensuite le médiateur seul prend le
relais on s'aperçoit on a nous deux
rendez-vous comme ça chaque mois où on
sélectionne à chaque fois 12 dossiers
donc 24 dossiers on s'aperçoit que parmi
les personnes qui viennent ça représente
80 % des personnes qui se déplacent à la
convocation du juge et on en a
aujourd'hui la moitié qui accepte de
partir euh pour une médiation donc c'est
un dispositif assez récent ça date du
mois de mai mais moi j'ai la faiblesse
de penser que ça peut donner de de de
bon résultats et on est tout à fait dans
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure on est
tout à fait dans dans les nouveaux
dispositifs voilà voulu par le Garde des
saut mais aussi par toute la communauté
judiciaire de de privilégier la mable
permet aussi de désembouteiller un peu
les les les il y a a cette ce facteur là
qui qui on peut pas il faut il faut pas
se cacher il y a peut y avoir une une
idée de de gérer aussi des stocks mais
non mais c'est pas c'est pas la seule
idée mais je
dire ça peut pas être que ça parce que
vous voyez là là je vous parle en vous
disant ça je vous parle je vous parle de
de 25 dossiers par mois là où là où on
en a plusieurs milliers dans dans nos
armoires donc ce n'est pas qu'une
gestion qu'une question de stock c'est
vraiment une chance qu'on peut donner au
partis et et qui maintenant vont je
pense la saisir de plus en plus je
disais ça parce qu'il y a eu il y a il y
a quelques temps un rapport on a pas le
rapport sauvé hein sur comité après les
comités des états généraux de la justice
qui parlait de délabrement de l'état de
la justice alors le mot est très fort
mais c'est vrai que voilà les les
tribunaux d'une façon générale et je
pense que le le tribunal de versaill ne
peut pas faire exception rend compte des
problèmes et de et d'abord d'ffectif euh
sur les 75 juges qui doivent être là
vous en avez 75 non j'en ai pas 75 ça
fait des années que je ne je nai jamais
le le le le compte au complet là
actuellement on est plutôt dans une
situation favorable on a que deux postes
deux personnes qui ne sont pas nommées
c'est-à-dire que voilà le le le le
ministère a nommé 73 au lieu d'en nommer
75 donc déjà il en manque deux par
principe et puis après bien sûr on a les
absences les maladies les maternités
tous ces t t tous ces événements de la
vie qui font que sur un effectif on est
rarement au complet par exemple
aujourd'hui voyez si on fait le compte
de de toutes les absences aujourd'hui
j'ai six absences h même s'il y a une
augmentation du budget de la justice va
de de voilà donc là ça c'est la
situation d'aujourd'hui pour autant et
vous le savez effectivement vous y
faites référence le ministre de la
Justice a mis en place un plan qu'il est
en train de soumettre au vote du
Parlement un plan d'action pour la
justice donc un plan quinquenal donc
jusqu'en 2027 qui permettra de renforcer
les moyens de la justice renforcer les
moyens en magistrat engreffier et puis
aussi une nouvelle fonction qu'on
appelle l'équipe autour du juge
c'est-à-dire c'est des des juristes qui
viendront nous nous nous assister nous
aider parce que c'est pareil dans dans
dans dans la mission du juge il y a
aussi des missions des activités de
recherche de de documents voilà qui pe
aussi être un peu délégué garder le juge
pour la dira la prestation
intellectuelle la la la
plus la plus délicate et et avoir autour
de soi des équipes qui nous permett de
de juger plus mais c'est vrai que les
Français se plaignent souv de la lenteur
de la justice mais on est un des pays
qui fait le moins d'eff pour son budgire
jusqu' voilà c'est un peu c'est un peu
la contradiction et le
paradoxe c'est tout à fait ça alors un
mot sur le l'état d'esprit des des
magistrats aujourd'hui
euh on a l'impression pour des raisons à
l'URE très diverses quis sont des
raisons de moyens comme vous le disiez
peut-être de crise aussi de de
l'autorité qui est un peu peu générale
qui dépasse évidemment la justice le le
métier de magistrat a beaucoup changé et
et même l'image des magistrats a changé
est-ce que vous c'est quelque chose que
vous ressentez oui c'est vrai que voilà
moi j'exerce maintenant ce métier depuis
presque un peu plus presqueun trentaine
d'années une trentaine d'années et et
c'est vrai que on voit notre métier
évoluer mais on le voit évoluer en même
temps que la société je crois vous vous
parliez de la crise de l'autorité oui
général on le voit bien tout le monde
tout le monde un peu le le dit la police
le dit la gendarmerie le dit enfin tout
toutes les fonctions d'autorité sont de
plus en plus remise en cause
l'enseignement il y a aussi toutes ces
questions qui qui qui nous traversent on
n'a pas le même rapport aux citoyens ou
les citoyens n'ont pas le même rapport
au service public à l'administration
d'une manière générale ou même à
l'autorité tout simplement et c'est vrai
que la fonction de juger est par
définition une fonction d'autorité et et
nous avons un public qui peut parfois
être difficile mais là encore l'activité
du tribunal tel que celui de Versailles
mais comme tous les tribunaux il y a il
y a deux versants il y a une fonction
d'autorité le fait de sanctionner ou
bien sûr mais il y a aussi et je le
disais le fait de trancher des conflits
et donc résoudre en quelque sorte les
conflits et puis c'est aussi une
fonction de protection par exemple c'est
un juge du tribunal qui est le juge des
tutelles qui va donc venir protéger les
personnes âgées euh euh mettre en place
des tuteurs qui vont les aider à gérer
leur patrimoine qui va protéger les
mineurs qui subissent des violences ou
ou ou qui sont en carence éducative
voilà donc il y a aussi cette mission et
dans ces missions là il faut quand même
reconnaître que pour le coup les
magistrats sont assez valorisés puisque
le public est en général très satisfait
de de de l'intervention du juge il est
moins évidemment quand il s'agit de
passer devant un tribunal correctionnel
pour se voir supprimer son permis de
conduire mais j'ai vu quand même que
vous aviez mis je sais pas s'il existe
toujours
une un groupe sur l'évaluation des
risques psychosociaux des magistrats de
ce tribunal quoi c'est la preuve que
voilà il y a il y ait oui c'est c'est la
cour d'appel de la cour d'appel de
Versailles avec le le premier président
et le procureur général qui ont souhaité
sur l'ensemble des tribunaux de la cour
d'appel de Versailles mettre en place
une réflexion déjà faire un diagnostic
de l'état des risques psychosociaux la
qualité de vie au travail et à partir
des constats qui ont été faits qui sont
je crois pas très différents en tout cas
ça a été confié à un consultant
extérieur qui a donc non seulement
l'habitude d'administration mais qui
voit aussi comment ça peut se passer
dans le privé j'allais presque dire on
est ni pire ni meilleur que les autres
on est un peu comme les autres
effectivement on a parfois de la
désespérance chez nous aussi mais bon
voilà vous direz que c'est peut-être un
btier plus difficile que quand vous
l'avez commencé disons que c'est un
métier à responsabilité c'est vrai
que c'est vrai on est quand même même
confronté je le disais tout à l'heure on
est confronté à des personnes qui ont
des problèmes et qui viennent nous nous
nous poser les problèmes et donc euh
quand on a des délais qui sont trop
longs quand on a des moyens insuffisants
ce qui a été le cas ces dernières années
ça s'améliore je le dis très clairement
ça s'améliore et on envoie les effets
mais c'est vrai que faire travailler nos
agents dans des conditions un petit peu
dégradées évidemment c'est difficile à
assurer et et et admettre et assumer
psychologiquement et donc oui c'est en
cela que euh il y a eu une dégradation
du du sentiment c'est aussi quand quand
vous recevez du public et que vous lui
dites que voilà l'affaire ne pourra être
jugée que dans 6 mois dans 7 mois dans 8
mois vous évidemment vous vous
confrontez à une réaction très négative
et pour autant vous n'avez pas d'autres
moyens et donc vous vous sentez
vous-même un peu remis en cause et et en
porte à faau donc c'est tout cela qui
nous appartient d'accompagner c'est
faire en sorte d'abord de réduire les
délais et puis ensuite d'accompagner nos
agents pour pour pour pouvoir vivre tout
cela au mieux je parlais de changement
aussi des des rapports de l'autorité je
crois qu'il y a une magistrate de la
Cour d'Assise qui a été agressé oui
effectivement elle il y a quelques
annéesà alors bon l'affaire est à
l'instruction donc je non non on va pas
r dire mais je veux dire voilà c'est
vrai que le on disait le respect mais
non non mais c'est vrai que c'est un peu
général non non mais bien entendu non
mais vous avez raison mais on le voit et
encore une fois je pense que bien sûr
pour les magistrats ça peut être le cas
pour les greffiers mais on le voit aussi
dans toutes les spères d'autorité je
veux dire les les attentats contre les
policiers quand même le département est
est bien placé pour le savoir euh voilà
les les attaques là aussi le département
est bien placé contre les enseignants
enfin je veux dire voilà les attentats
les plus marquants ces dernières années
contre des personnes qui exerçaient une
mission de service public et par le seul
fait qu'elle représente